you wrote the iconic song that was a
lightning rod f the police yeah and I'm
wearing a tie so I got to say that and
you wrote it as a response so many years
ago to police brutality and then there
was almost a feeling in this country
that okay by people who weren't in touch
that we've gotten past that and that's
all we read about in the news these days
is that issue is has not gone away how
does it feel that you were talking about
that 20-some odd years ago and it's
still the issue right now facing America
well you know I mean it doesn't feel
good that the issue is still relevant
you know I think I thought we were
speaking on something people didn't know
about and we realized people know about
it but just kind of brushed it under the
rug on or was like that's yesterday's
headlines and now you're sending more
and more you know I just think we got a
hold people accountable you know whether
they're in uniform on our uniform when
they abuse people we got to hold them
accountable you know the body cams are
working you know and just basically you
know the public shame of a cop stepping
over the line I think it's starting to
penetrate these issues these cops and
you know hopefully we're getting some
kind of understanding yeah okay well we
have hey thanks for watching please
subscribe to my youtube channel so they
will stop making me shoot these videos
please